[Music]
hi
dino here in this video we will get to
know
apogee's api analytics
there are three big pieces to managing
an api program exposing your apis
enabling others to consume your apis and
then
measuring that activity apis are
foundational for digital business
so it's very important to have complete
visibility
into api performance you want to track
developer usage api usage trends
error rates geographic distribution
all of these metrics and more are
available to you through the apigee edge
platform
so you can analyze your digital business
in real time
let me show you some of what you get
navigate to the analytics menu
on the left hand side let's take a look
the api proxy performance chart
will show traffic volumes and response
times for your apis
this is such valuable insight some
customers create an
apigee pass-through proxy on existing
services just to get this view
you can view data for a specific proxy
or all proxies
look back an hour a day a week
or more and it's built in you don't have
to do anything to get this
so nice this report can be a great
resource for your developers
and devops team
the cache performance chart shows
utilization of the built-in apigee edge
cache for your apis
this is really handy for helping to
optimize performance and efficiency
the geo map shows you the geographic
source of traffic
it's marvelous to be able to track api
proxy usage
by geo to see where usage originates
the latency analysis chart is invaluable
when managing to a response time goal
stable performance is key for a quality
user experience
this apogee chart shows tp50
tp95 and tp99
that's average response time as well as
95th
and 99th percentile when you have spikes
in tp99 it indicates that other pieces
in your system are not delivering stable
performance under load
this chart pinpoints that problem
the traffic composition report shows you
the top proxies
products apps or developers by traffic
volumes
obviously valuable when managing an api
program
and you can create your own custom
reports based on the individual metrics
that are collected by apogee edge
like latency ip address path
and response status code
this is just a quick sample to get these
charts for your traffic
all you need to do is create an api
proxy in apigee edge
and direct client applications to use it
and of course all of the data presented
visually in these charts is available
via an api so you can export it into
your own
analysis tools okay
that's the quick introduction to apogee
edge analytics
it gives you visibility into key
performance and operating metrics for
your apis
and if you want to know more dive into
the product documentation
or visit the community till next time
keep it digital